I'm gonna start with you not to leave
that's okay sure sure hanging how does
it feel to have directed Jennifer
Lawrence pretty I think who Frances was
really great he just said you know if
you wanna tell genders like to the right
or the left or you know stop or a
starter then feel free to ad-lib which
was very gracious of him than freeing
for me because else I didn't really I
was standing there pretending to look at
a monitor a lot um and Jen was always
great stating character didn't and a few
of those some organic moments made it
into the movie so it was great for me
she was a great director and Donald
you said he sit there and it just
terrifies me because he's president snow
with wait for the roles instead of the
poppy but it's it's likely a poppy today
and well and I want to ask if you guys
did much preparation between yourself
and Jen in terms of preparing for those
moments where you were on screen
together
or did you keep your distance ahead of
them we're not allowed to disclose that
no we didn't do anything we went to work
you know did you spare it ourselves for
the role I don't really find that my
personal relationship with people
affects the characters really I mean
it's obits I do fellas just Wornall we
were mostly focused on our dating
relationship and Oh Jen I want to ask
you maybe that was one of the biggest
surprises from from this experience was
was dating Donald Sutherland but for you
what was the biggest surprise from being
part of this this incredible journey
what surprised you the most surprised
yeah what have you come away being
surprised about I mean this isn't like a
when I was 20 and I signed on to these I
was I kind of knew I was like okay this
is a long road and you're gonna have
moments of regrets and but I ultimately
think that this is the right thing to do
and I was like I'm going to be 25 by the
time all this is over like that will
never happen and
and so I think what surprises me is how
upset I was when I racked I kind of when
I signed them I was like okay it's five
years you know he'll get through it and
I was so sad to go and and I never had
one moment of a grat like I thought I
would I really genuinely loved being a
part of these movies and have never
looked back
thank you and Jillian present coin and I
kind of constantly think about her her
name her backstory
you know kind of where she came from and
who and what made her into the person
that she is is that something that you
kind of thought about and talked about
it yeah I mean Francis and I talked
about it a lot and we talked about how
do you rate this kind of political
narrative which is obviously a very
familiar one historically someone starts
out as a true revolutionary someone who
is speaking for the people and wants to
and and really wants change and then
over the course of her journey becomes
corrupted by power and her desire for
revenge and ends up as much of a despot
as the person she's trying to overthrow
that's what he was really interesting
and really really wonderful to put in
the context of his very personal story
this young woman trying to figure out
where her moral Center was and how she
determines right from wrong so I mean I
loved doing it and welcomed the
opportunity to get to work with all
these great thank you almost of chime in
and say that Julianne actually brought a
lot of ideas to the character Julianne
somebody who loved the books and very
much wanted to play coin and from the
very beginning her ideas actually
informed the how we wrote the character
because in the books because they're all
from Katniss point of view you only ever
see coin through Katz's eyes and Katniss
has a young person's perspective on this
authoritarian figure hmm and so I think
the coin
of the movies is a much more fully
realized and dimensionalized character
which is something I know Suzanne was
thrilled about was the chance the chance
to see you know a side of the character
that you can't see when you're seeing
her through captain's eyes but Julianne
brought a lot of her own ideas to the
character and was really we were all
excited to see how much more humanity I
think coin has as a character but yeah
and I wanted that idea I think
especially for for young people that
that idea I think that we've all felt
this when we feel politically
disillusioned you're like wait a minute
I thought it was this way and you're
telling me it wasn't you know so I
thought that was sort of an important
idea and I think so so resonant and the
suzanne somers great thank you
and before we throw out to the press
we've got a couple of competition
winners and also and a young lady who's
been invited along this morning from
make-a-wish charity so I'm going to give
Sara the first question so sorry if
you'd like to stand up and get a
microphone to you please Jan what has
been your favorite moment on set out of
all four films oh God
we met last night yeah hi good to see
you again
um favorite moment I will it's hard
because Josh and I always want to say
Hawaii for catching fire because we were
in Hawaii but Liam is in there so when
the whole group wasn't together it
couldn't be as fun um in Berlin we had
we had a really good time all of us are
all staying in the same like apartment
building and we were all on the same
floor and nobody locked their doors what
he woke me up one morning and in my
mouth guard and I was like and Josh and
Liam got in a tug of war fight with
their mouths that went on for like 15
minutes um we just had a really I guess
berlin's we were all together and all
kind of living in the same place wait
sorry that wasn't a filming but I'm done
like you saw and we got to competition
winners run stuff at Olivia if you'd
like to stand up this is for Jennifer
was any added pressure playing one of
the only strong female characters in
film um yeah I mean just pressure that
came from I really loved this character
I really respected her and when I read
the books I found her so inspiring she
inspired me so I had my own kind of
personal pressure of doing a good job
and living out living up to her and and
having this character fully developed so
yeah there was definitely a certain
pressure that I was more than happy to
take on and was honored to be a part of
this is a general question what have you
all done since gone first Hunger Games
luckily John insistence you've been part
of this in terms of what you've learned
from being part of this this project
I've learned that they don't have to be
two mutually exclusive things to be a
mega blockbuster and to have some real
meaning and message in a movie I think
in a story I think Hunger Games as a
phenomenon has rewritten the rulebook of
what can be commercially viable and it's
long overdue that a franchise can have
such important messages and hope to
inspire younger generation and still
make the money mend their money and
still get the bums on seats but so
hopefully it's about the quality of the
writing as Nina always so eloquently
talks about Suzanne Collins so that we
can be more sophisticated and more
respectful of our audiences when we make
big blockbusters brilliant what we
answer thank you very much for them yeah
I go to open to the floor now everyone's
floored by that one yeah and here we go
gentlemen in the second row please Ben
Lee from The Guardian for a film of this
scale is surprisingly bleak what do you
think says about the time they were in
the box of this dark is being released
there's necessary it's the bleakest of
times if that was your question is
I is a blockbuster so believe I don't
think it's bleak I think it's very
optimistic to be truthful but they'll
lead up to that optimistic moment is
bleak because these times are bleak and
this is an allegory for this time it's a
it's an effort on the part of Suzanne
Collins or on everyone making this film
participating in it to inform young
people I mean for older people it's too
late but for young people to catalyze
within some kind of political action
that will engage them in in
participation that will change the
status quo our conditions are very bleak
we have wars everywhere we have
uprisings that are failing we have a
climate that is destroying our world and
if we don't change it and the only
people who can change it are young
people if we don't change it we're all
dead so that's what it is that's why it
was made and it can change it's just up
to you guys thank you and we hope that
this film would make you aware of that
great you're right to not Donald wants
no question quite answer thank you and
next question please from our audience
first leading the row in the middle
thank you
hi it's Sarah from M Jabbar Jeanette and
my question is for Jennifer and I love
in this franchise that Katniss is
relationships a sort of secondary to
like everything else that's going on and
what lesson about love do you think
young Watchers can take from the story
of Katniss and Peeta um our conversation
about the relationships and the romance
between Katniss and Peeta and Katniss
and Gale is that these kids are living
in a time that we don't recognize they
they they're dealing with problems that
are so much bigger than they are that
don't have the luxury of a first kiss or
having ever wondering wondering if he
likes her too or what all of these
things that we kind of take for granted
they just don't have that they're living
in such a different world um that was
always the biggest conversation that we
had with them but also Pete it
represents comfort to Katniss Katniss is
a warrior at the end of these movies
she's a veteran
she doesn't want excitement she doesn't
want another warrior hunter like Gale
you Peeta represents the life the
Katniss is sought for all of these
movies is just peace and a safe family
it's another question for Jennifer I'm
just wondering when you're playing a
character like this who's so
strong-willed and so so inspiring Oh
Jeff and someone you've paid for a
number of years you ever find that she
almost infiltrates your personal life
you ever face up a decision you've
almost faint what would Katniss do in
this situation no I'm not and this is
really annoying because I because
somebody like asked me they were talking
about like gender pay gap and they're
like do you feel like your character
inspired you to write about gender pay
gap nicely yeah you know playing her for
four year and then like it's on like
Time magazine like Katniss Everdeen
womens Jennifer Lawrence to write an
essay about a psychotic aunt just like
say anything um hey it's like characters
are was separate from you
they also come from you um I find
Katniss inspiring period when I read the
books and the script and it began you
know and bodying but or whatever
everything about her is to inspire
that's why she's the Mockingjay that's
why she's a leader so of course I was
inspired but I don't
ww Cady there's a famous primitive
painter and now dead in the United
States who has asked a question
her name is Grandma Moses
and they said what do you think about
this and she said I don't know what I
think until I hear what I say and it's a
little bit like that as an actor you're
not influenced by your character until
your character appears in front of you
it's not you it's something that you
have channeled and that appears and
participates in your life so you are
influenced in that respect I believe
that is so true there have been so many
times where I'll see what I feared to
realize that when we started this I was
nearly four times your age and now I'm
just barely more than three times
handi no you're dating I just wanted if
we could expand a little what you were
saying earlier Natalie about how this
franchise shows respect for audiences
and the things that you've got right I
just wondered whether you could
elaborate and to say exactly what you
think this has got right where others
have got wrong and what any of the
actors on the panel would like to see
films in the future take as a lesson I
don't know whether you meant it was the
reputation of women or minorities or
what uniquely well there's a list of
what these this franchise has got right
you know there's a long list um what I
what you asked me about before was um
that it's not condescending it's not
patronizing to its younger audience and
fully understands and appreciates that
they can process all these and explore
cathartic ly explore ideas of the
consequences of war tyrannical
oppression Liberty a human being
struggling with their sense of self
identity questions of love and loss
sacrifice um it doesn't sugarcoat
anything Donald said something very
interesting in our previous um
conference that is true he said Donald
said that um Francis Lawrence has made a
movie without which his lacks
sentimentality and um
this overwhelming need often that
Hollywood has to maybe sugarcoat things
to make them more palatable ultimately
doesn't help our younger generation
they've got so much to deal with whether
it be climate change or you know
education fees to basically get a
standard education and austerity they've
got so much on their plate don't be
lying to them about what the world is
really like doesn't help them give them
an opportunity in a movie like this to
explore how they handle the future
basically but then the other list
includes fantastic three-dimensional
characters for both genders so on so
forth yes Nina as a producer does it
kind of the the success of this
franchise in this these films and the
way that Natalie's described on does
that give you
I guess few to go onwards as a producer
to kind of almost you know take on that
kind of mantle that this film is done to
two other films that you work on
absolutely I mean this film has been you
know I think an extraordinary privilege
for all of us for one because we've so
connected with the material but we've
connected with each other and it sets a
a bar that's very a very high bar in
terms of the kind of experiences that
you want to have but I think you know
I've always felt that audiences are
smart young people are smart and they
you know they deserve better than often
what we provide in Hollywood and you
know this movie has been a great
reinforcement of that ambition that that
audiences are every bit as ambitious as
filmmakers will let them be and that
it's on all of us to keep aspiring and
keep demanding that we we raise the bar
and not to be not pander and not to
patronize ever and I think also when it
comes to adaptation when
find something that is special and great
to do justice to it
and that to never forget the origins of
the opportunity
you